- [Interviewer] Alright, Samara?
- Yes, Samara.
- [Interviewer] And where are
you from originally, Samara?
- [Samara] I was raised in Bolivia,
born in California, and both
my parents are from Bolivia.
I lived all over, all over places, so,
Hong Kong, I lived in
Indonesia for a little bit,
Bolivia, New Jersey, Florida.
- [Interviewer] Oh, wow.
- Yeah. I was in Bolivia 'til 12.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and you
grew up with both parents?
- No, I grew up with, um,
my grandma a little bit,
and my mom.
Because my mom had me when she was 15,
so my grandma helped her,
she was still a baby when she had me.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- Um, my, it was, um, it was nice.
There are some points that are nice,
but, you obviously remember
the bad things for some reason.
So, my mom...(chokes up)
Hold on a second.
My mom, she um, she wasn't,
my dad, my dad left
when I was like six, to America.
Which is okay.
And I had my grandma, who raised me.
My mom, she was there too, but
she dated these guys all the time,
they weren't good people.
And so she wasn't around that much.
And she used to drink a lot.
Yeah, so, these guys,
sometimes they were nice, but like,
I had, there was one who I saw him
as a father-figure.
And, he, um, like he, I guess
he molested me or something.
- How old were you?
- And the other one
used to hit my mom.
- [Interviewer] How old
were you when this happened?
- I was like, six or something.
And the other one used to hit my mom.
But, I was with my grandma,
and she was a good grandma.
There are nice parts about my infancy.
Like, we use to go to out in the country,
in Bolivia, like there were cows and,
you go and ride horses, with my grandpa.
He's not really my grandpa,
but he's the one who was
married to my grandma.
Yeah, but, my mom's not a bad mom,
she not like that anymore.
She tries to be a good mom
to my three-year-old brother now.
When I was 11 she graduated
from lawyer school,
and then we left the country, to Florida.
Because we couldn't
get away from this guy.
This guys wouldn't respect nobody.
Yeah, we left, and then, I started,
I was in America,
and I was a good girl before, ya know?
Like I had, I was a good student.
And then, I know I was very rebellious.
So, I guess I just...at 14,
I started fighting with my mom,
like every teenager,
starts fighting with their mother.
And I asked my dad if I
could move in with him,
so I went to New Jersey to live with him.
It wasn't a good experience either,
but the first time I tried drugs
was with my dad's brother.
And like, it's weird,
because he was watching porn
and he asked me if I wanted to smoke weed.
Like, he don't act like he didn't see
that I was in my car,
and it was a pipe,
and I never saw it
but I smoked weed.
And that's the first
time I tried anything.
I went to an art school.
I started like, cutting myself and stuff.
I didn't even get it from a movie,
it just, it was like a
natural instinct to do.
Because I was really
depressed, with my dad.
My dad was really overprotective,
like, I lived with him only six months.
But he wouldn't let me talk to anybody.
Or like, hang out with any boys,
or anything, ya know?
And even when I went to work,
he would think I would lie to him,
if I went somewhere else.
He's a little bit
sick in the head, in a way, huh?
Very overprotective.
But I don't talk to my dad anymore.
Last time I saw him,
I had an infection in my face
and I was shooting up in a hospital
and he was sleeping next to me
I didn't know he saw me.
And then in the morning
he told the nurses that he saw me
shoot up in the hospital at night.
They were looking around my room
in the morning when I woke up
to look for my shit.
And they found my drugs and stuff.
And I got mad at my dad
and I told him to fuck off.
I don't wanna see him again.
And then he left.
But, um, where was I?
- [Interviewer] What was your drug?
Or what is your drug?
- Right now?
Right now, it's um,
I take bars here and there,
but it's mostly fentanyl.
It used to be heroin,
and crystal, and weed, and yeah.
Everything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
all the heroin addicts
turn into fentanyl.
- Now it's fentanyl, yeah,
because heroin doesn't do shit to us.
And now fentanyl doesn't do shit to me.
Ya know? I have to find, like,
there's different types of fentanyl now.
Like um, there's shitty ones,
and there's like card fentanyl now
that they're selling on the streets.
And then there's this liquidy one
that's really good.
And there's blue fentanyl
there's pink fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] And how
much do you spend a day?
- Um, I turn, I didn't choose to,
I didn't ever want to like trade,
flip stuff to make money,
but I, the way I do it is
I've been helping people get stuff.
And from there I get it.
I get money to get my own shit,
I get it for cheap but that's because um,
I'm a girl.
And every dealer that I've had
has always tried to
do shit with me and they always, ya know?
You gotta do what you gotta do to survive.
It's horrible, being sick.
- [Interviewer] Do you date
guys that sell for money?
- [Samara] You know what?
I never wanted to like,
I don't like it.
And, it's horrible,
like I'm so against people,
from what my mom has been through.
I fucking hate guys
that take advantage of women.
Like if I see someone
being taken advantage of,
like this girl, the other day, yesterday,
she almost got hit by this guy
because he thought he took his light,
his (snaps) flashlight.
But yeah, there's just,
you're in the streets,
people, people do shit.
Like you can't even sleep at night
because people go in your tent, right?
So um, yeah, um,
I get money from helping people out
helping people get their shit.
And I flip it.
I've been pretty much selling.
And yeah, if I have to do other shit
like you gotta do what you gotta do.
I do whatever it takes.
I never planned to sleep with the dealer
I was sleeping with,
but I had to I guess.
I ended up liking him at the end,
but I didn't, if they try
you can't say no because
then they get mad.
And then they'll stop hooking you up.
And I get a good deal.
So, that's how I am.
- Where are you sleeping?
- Where do I sleep?
I was sleeping,
I lived with this Mexican
family for a little bit.
I slept in their living room.
I slept in a tent here,
I've slept in the streets before.
Yesterday I slept at um,
there's this guy who knows the dealer
and I really like him.
He had his friend, who
they go and they boost
I boost too, ya know? For the stores.
But since my face, sometimes,
when you look too bad, they know,
they can tell, ya know?
You gotta look decent,
like a normal person
in order for them not to look at you.
But I used to make like $180
just boosting.
I boost sometimes though, still.
I go to places where it's a rich,
rich neighborhood, because
they don't have security
in the stores there.
And I just go in and out,
like 60 seconds, in and out.
Because that's all you got
before they see your face,
and then they're like,
"Oh can I...?" Yeah. So.
I do that. But, yeah, I flip it.
I flip the money, and I,
the whole day I spend going on the bus
like, trading and giving people shit.
- [Interviewer] Your drug
cost you how much a day?
- My drug, um, I think I do like
a gram and a half.
To be honest, I'm gonna tell you,
I sell the fentanyl for like $120,
$110 a gram.
- Which is pretty good.
- So if you weren't...
- [Samara] And I get it for $70,
so I guess it would cost me like,
$70...for me like $120
for a gram and a half.
- [Interviewer] But if you were buying it
on the street it would be double that.
- Yeah, if I didn't have the hook up.
Yeah, it would be $70...$140, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Almost $300 a day.
- Yeah, like $300 a day
if I didn't have the hook ups, like I do.
But I know a lot of dealers
and then I just, ya know?
I got the hook ups,
so that's how I keep doing.
- Do you have children?
- I do.
Yeah, I do.
- [Interviewer] Where are they?
- Um, yeah, his name in Calio
he lives in San Diego.
He's two-years-old.
- [Interviewer] Who's raising him?
- His dad.
But I always wanted to be with him,
I promised to be (sighs with emotion)
to be there for him.
Like I said, before he turns two
I'm gonna be there.
Because then they're going
to start remembering stuff.
But um, I didn't know I was a drug addict.
I didn't even know about the NA program.
I've been sober before.
Until um, I got pregnant and then
I couldn't stop, I
couldn't stop doing drugs.
And I was already four months pregnant.
(chokes back a sob)
And I was still doing drugs,
so my parents, they lied to me.
They said, "Hey, come
visit us in Indonesia,"
because that's where they were living at.
And um, ya know, "Come
visit us in Indonesia,"
because I was pregnant,
and I was like, "Okay,
I'll come visit you guys."
By then I was living with this dealer,
like 70-year-old dealer, dude,
who like, 12 girls come in and out.
He doesn't even do heroin
he only does crystal.
But he has it, so he can fuck all these
fucking 20-year-old girls, ya know,
he could be their fucking...
he could be their grandpa.
Yeah, I went there and they're like,
"Your baby daddy told us that
you've been doing heroin,
and you're fucking pregnant
we're not going to let you
do any damage to the baby,
so you're going to fucking stay here
until you're almost
ready to have the baby."
So I stayed in Indonesia for a little bit,
and when I was 8 months and a half
I went back to San Diego to have my baby.
And I was really scared that
they would take him away.
(Sighs)
So I asked the doctor
and he's like, "If you get
a lot of tests negative
then they might let you keep him."
I made sure that the last three tests,
they were negative, I didn't do anything.
(Samara swallowing back a sob)
Until he was four months,
and then I got back into it.
(stutters) I started again.
And then I asked my mom,
I OD'd, first time I OD'd I got scared.
But I OD'd like six times after that.
- [Interviewer] This is on fentanyl?
- Um, no, on heroin.
And like four times on fentanyl.
The first time I tried fentanyl I shot it.
Because I used to only shoot.
They had to use two Narcans on me.
I was with my boyfriend back then.
I didn't wake up, the first one.
And then when I woke up,
I was like, what the fuck?
'Cause like, Narcan
makes you sober, right?
And I didn't realize how bad it was.
You're so fucking, not here,
that you don't realize, what like,
how bad this life that you're living.
And like, look how the fuck we're living!
And then after, I had Narcan
he's like, "Now you gotta stay awake,
so I don't die."
And then he OD'd too.
And like, I had to keep him awake.
Like the whole fucking night,
so he doesn't die.
After I'm sober there,
like, just got hit by Narcan.
It was a bad experience.
But yeah, the first time, I got scared.
I already had my baby.
They took him away, when I told them,
I told my baby daddy,
'cause at some point
we went back to live with him again.
I wanted us to be a family, ya know?
Like, mostly for my son to have a dad
in his life, I wanted him to...
I want the best for my son.
I never wanted to do drugs with him.
Even when I was breast feeding,
at some point I moved to
Florida with my friend,
and I started doing crack and heroin,
and my baby, he didn't wanna do um,
he didn't wanna, do the bottle,
so I had to breast feed him
while I was doing this.
And like, I have even left him
in the room, and like
stole my friend's car
to go and get like, to find drugs.
And he's like six-months-old.
I've given him bars,
because I was too sick
to take care of him.
And I needed to sleep.
And it's just really fucked up, like
how can you do that to a baby?
But when he was 10 months,
I told his dad, and his
dad called the cops.
And I went to jail.
I told him that I was still using,
and that I needed help.
I couldn't stop.
And yeah, he got mad and called the cops.
By the time I got out of jail
I had a restraining order
and I was homeless.
That's the first time
that I became homeless.
And they took my baby away,
I couldn't meet,
I couldn't get close to him
'cause I had a restraining order.
So, um, yeah.
I haven't lived with my baby ever since.
I'm always like, I'm gonna get clean.
And the time goes by,
and you don't have time.
The whole day, you're um, you spend it
trying to um, get money to survive,
to eat, to fucking,
where you gonna shower?
Like the whole day, you spend it
driving buses to make money.
So you can survive.
So you don't have time to ever
do these things.
But I was supposed to be there,
my son just turned two on September 15.
And, yeah, I didn't make
it, for his birthday.
I started with this Peruvian guy
who let me stay in his trailer.
But he's like, he promised,
like I ask him first,
"Do you need me to do anything,
in order for me to stay here?"
'Cause I don't wanna have to do something
I don't want to. Like
why you wanna help me?
I'm a girl on the streets.
He doesn't even do drugs, it's weird.
And he said, "No." But later,
now he's like, "I'll help
you out if you need help,
you just need to help me out."
And yeah, I don't stay with him anymore
because even one night,
since he has one bed,
I caught him like putting his hands
under the covers, ya know?
Like, that's...you can't
even fucking sleep.
Everybody's fucked up.
So um, I'm planning on
putting a tent here now.
Because I don't really have
a place to sleep every night.
It's different for me.
Before, my ex-boyfriend,
in what used to be the car of his dad.
I have this guy, I just, I'm just saw,
like, I'm just starting to see last night,
and we slept at his friend's house,
he went boosting the whole night,
he said he was going to come back,
he never came back.
And I'm on methadone,
which is more fucked because,
it's another drug.
And now I'm gonna get, ya know?
But I wanna get off this shit,
I really am done.
I'm so tired of living
this way. (sniffles)
But um, I fucked up,
my family gave me so many chances,
they don't trust me anymore.
And I don't blame them.
They don't want me around,
and I understand, but,
yeah I only have myself now.
I don't have anybody.
I can't trust anybody.
The guys, they only want
sex when you're here.
And women, I don't know,
I don't have any women friends, only one.
I do this, I um,
have to do shit everyday,
different shit everyday
in order to survive.
Like tonight, I don't know
where I'm gonna sleep at.
But maybe the Burgman guy's house,
I sleep in his closet now
because he has another
friend living there.
And the closet is like this space
but, it's something.
As soon as I have money,
I'm gonna buy a tent.
I'm gonna put it over there.
And at least I have Mike, Big Mike,
ya know, like I help him, um, yeah.
And I think I'm gonna have to like,
sometimes have to sleep with people now.
Man, I don't want to.
But sometimes I have to.
It's disgusting.
Like I'm really sensitive
about that part.
Like, before, I used
to protect my friends,
like I used to be really,
like against that.
Especially the way I
was raised in Bolivia,
like people, you have to be like,
come from a good family,
come from a good last name, ya know?
Be in a good school,
that's how they see you.
Because everybody knows each other.
And it's like your morals, but
I've had good morals,
and now it's like, it
fucking hurts me still.
No drug numbs you enough,
the shit that you have to do to be okay,
to feel okay, doing the
shit that you have to do.
Like right now, I just went to pick up,
my dealer, he didn't even give me,
I was coming to, ring up my fucking,
eat with this food.
I eat with the money I made.
And he stole from me.
Like two grams, he doesn't
wanna fucking give me.
'Cause I bought that shit,
and I'm the one that loses money.
So now I'm fucked.
I have to like start again.
I don't know how, I have to wait.
But I'm probably gonna
have to go boost today.
And I have to fuck someone, to be honest,
to um, in order to survive.
But I wanna get off this shit.
I'm going to, like I want to.
I'm tired of this.
(inhales deeply)
But I just don't get a chance.
And it's hard like,
you say I want to, and we mean it.
But um, once you're sick, it's different.
Then you're just like, "Fuck this,
like I'm gonna do whatever it takes
in order to stop feeling this way.
I can't fucking feel this way."
'Cause it's really horrible to be sick.
But you really want to like,
like my mom has tried, has tried,
to get me sober, and get a hotel room.
And by the third day, I would like,
steal her money.
Just fucking leave her.
- Where is your mom now?
Um, they just moved, they just moved,
they rented the house from Indonesia,
they stayed there for like 4 years,
and they just moved to San Diego,
because the plan was, like last year,
for them to move here.
I was supposed to live with them,
and to have the kids together.
My little brother, who's three...four.
And my little baby together, who's three.
And us to live together in San Diego,
so we could be close to my baby.
But um, and I was supposed
to have custody too,
like at least have custody.
But I haven't seen my baby,
and he doesn't see me. (sniffles)
And his dad told me like, the first months
after I left, he would wake up
in the middle of the night,
and be like, "Mama!"
And this shit fucks with you.
I don't like talking
(mumbles while crying).
A lot of people don't know I have a kid.
I don't like talking about him.
'Cause I don't like feeling anything,
I don't wanna feel anything.
Yeah and I try to not have any feelings
for anybody.
Because I can't fucking take more anymore.
So when guys try and date me,
like, "I'll take care of you,
I'll be there for you." The promise you.
Like that guy last night,
where the fuck is he today, ya know?
Like I gave him what he wanted,
which was fucking sex, and now
where the fuck is he?
So I don't let anybody get close to me.
Like I really am feisty with guys.
Like I don't talk to anybody.
Guys try talking to you
when you're in the street just walking
"What's up shorty?" Whatever, ya know?
I don't say shit, man.
If anything, I have scissors
or a knife on me, ya know?
'Cause I already know better, ya know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But yeah, you just have to,
everyday, you never know
where you're gonna be
or what's gonna happen to you
or what you're gonna have to do.
But one day, I always say,
the next day I'm gonna get clean,
I'm gonna stop.
Honestly, I don't even know why
I keep doing fentanyl,
because I'm on Methadone,
and it blocks the fentanyl.
So I don't even know why I do it.
So now, I did, I did crack today.
I haven't done crack in fucking,
a year or something.
But I did today.
I guess 'cause I'm a drug addict.
I wanna stop, though,
I just wanna be normal.
I wanna be part of my kid's life.
I don't wanna be rich or nothing, man,
I just want a house, and
be able to support my baby
and be a good mom.
I have my family and people I love
close to me.
Like even when you're with people
and you go do work, like boost and stuff,
you always feel alone, like you're alone.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's a rough neighborhood.
- Yeah, because everybody's selfish.
This drug turns you selfish.
Like, you become a person...
You become someone you would, you would
before like, judge.
But um, fuck, I hate the person that I am.
Like, I don't like it.
And I hate when people treat me
the way they treat me.
And I can't do anything about it.
People that see me on the streets,
I used to be a person,
like an okay person.
Like look good, not have like abscesses
or shit like that, man.
I almost died once,
I had to stay in a hospital for two months
because I had endocarditis.
Yeah but, this thing on my face,
like fuck, I used to look normal,
but now I'm like, "How dare
they treat me like that."
But it's because I look different now.
You don't know that I used
to be a decent person.
But, you can't blame them.
- [Interviewer] Samara, thank
you so much for talking to me.
- Yeah, no problem.
- Good luck with getting
back with your son.
- Thank you.
- Good luck.